what would you like to do next or even
if it's in 10 years what's something on
your bucket list of the producer and a
filmmaker I want to play a real person
and I think for me Brittany
would be Britney Spears Millie Bobby
Brown may want to play the princess of
pop on the big screen but Brit she
seemingly just shut that ish down
hard try to keep it kind of professional
Millie revealed her dream role on the
Drew Barrymore show Monday I think her
story
festival resonates with with me just
growing up in the public eye watching
her videos watching interviews of her
when she was younger I mean same thing
with you it's like I see the Scramble
for words and I don't know her but when
I look at pictures of her I feel like I
could I could tell her story in the
right way in hers only and Brit well see
him she caught wind of all that and
weighed in on Instagram Tuesday writing
in part quote good news good news still
breathing I hear about people wanting to
do movies about my life dude I'm not
dead that feels like uh no the pop star
also slammed her fam in the caption
adding it's pretty clear they preferred
me dead I guess my family is going to
lock their doors now
[Music]
of course the Grammy winner has hasn't
shied away from using social media to
speak her mind ever since her 13-year
conservatorship ended last year what
does she want to do once this
conservative ship ends for the first
time in about 13 years that decision
will be up to Brittany and only Brittany
and that's a great thing
he's called out her
her ex-husband Kevin Federline and her
sister Jamie Lynn I love and support my
sister and I respect her healing process
and however she has to work through
things and all I ask is that I you know
have that same space because it's
important and most recently she
addressed Alexa Nicholas's claim that
Brittany yelled at her on the set of Zoe
101 after Jamie Lynn told her sister
that she was being bullied on set
want a great
I miss you I miss you too oh
please move back in with us okay I have
an adult screaming at me saying I'm
never gonna work in this industry again
she told me okay and it's pretty Spears
and so I'm sitting there
just in shock and I go I'm gonna puke
Alexa added that Britney apologized for
the incident and following the interview
the singer said sorry again writing in
part on Instagram quote I am sorry for
ever hurting your feelings well you know
we're all human so as for Millie she may
not get to play Britney but she has a
lot of projects to celebrate like anola
homes too I know the homes she's a
detective looks like she blow over in
the wind not only the star of this but a
producer as well so you've got to be
over the moon for a sequel I know I know
I'm really grateful and Netflix gave me
the opportunity to create this character
again and the final season of stranger
things have you wrapped your mind around
the final season of stranger things I
have I'm coming to terms with it slowly
so I'm ready I'm ready
[Music]